the returning officer of the above
election do hereby give notice that the
number of votes reported for each
candidate at the said election is as
follows darlington Emily Catrin Labour
Party seventeen thousand four hundred
and ninety one gram for living Democrats
3575 Lancaster John Mark the
Conservative Party candidate 27 märklin
Jennifer mckelvey Green Party 2255
multimap day Richard independent 112
Riley David my for me you Kip 6852
katherine jane trade unionist and
socialist coalition and 63 the number of
ballot papers which 213 the turnout was
sixty six point six seven percent and I
do hereby declare that John Mark
Lancaster is duly elected
thank you sir is very late so I will be
a long day it's been a very long evening
thank you so much thank you sir yeah it
has been a long night it's been a
fantastic result thank you to my agent
in town zoning and Anita campaign staff
but thank you also to the other capitals
it's been an excellent campaign as a
city we are at our best when we are
united and I'm sure that we can win this
and work together to continue to make
milton keynes the best place to live and
work in the UK